okay Diaz there are only two witnesses
who were close enough to the crash to
see something ones on his way here
already his name is Marshawn Lynch
Marshawn Lynch Marshawn Lynch the
football player I don't know his hobbies
it just says here he's unemployed
retired not getting anything out of him
he's always getting fired for refusing
to talk to the press oh it's kind of one
my heroes well it may be tough friend it
may take a while but I'm sure we'll get
him open up sir there are some vaults
you just can't open I see anything I'll
see you Mike a cedilha it was a good
chicken cheese walk but they forgot my
pico de gallo I mean while I was a
little boy my mom used to make this uh
she used to call it faux cheese what
y'all calling for how come they never
made quesadillas with sausage you throw
some tomato sauce in there they call it
a piece of Dylan what you think what is
going on are gonna save all the security
DVRs but I need some way of getting to a
station unnoticed I have an idea on how
to smuggle you in but it'll be a tight
fit I'm flexible I do a lot of yoga you
do yoga helps keep me centered if you
ask me about it again I'll hunt you down
and face off okay good good play know
what I don't ask a pelican I got the
DVRs actually that that's my lint
violators oblong my name is Lulu okay
sounds like we got a plan let's get your
training hey I've been looking for you
before you decide what to do with Sam
there's someone I think you should talk
to
miss Miriam surprise I tracked down your
old ballet coach I bought I ran to
remind you of the effect a kind
nurturing presence can have on a young
life hello dear have you continued to
dance no miss Miriam well there's no
surprise in that you always were a lazy
ox what's this now look at your posture
you look as if you should be ringing the
bells that note Radames Miriam was not
nurturing at all
all right ox let's see what you forgot
ah six seven eight eyes up shoulders
down well that wasn't terrible
see Serge tough love works damn it Terry
proved the wrong point party round to
the quiz winner gets a question mark
crown so cool um I'll take lonely arts
and crafts for 800 first of all I've
made many friends through arts and
crafts and how many of them are googly
eyes and secondly it's a drinking game
get a question wrong do a shot oh and
the questions they're all about Rosa but
none of us know anything about Rosa
everyone's about to get a real ham roof
what is my favorite soup chicken noodle
potato makes car freaking noodle
I mean Schauder damn it you're all wrong
I've never had to don't bother they all
sec three good disembowelment guys I was
a baby my first word was Dada
great
[Music]
wrong I can totally do a handstand good
luck following this party dish all right
well you're up where we're going a
restaurant specifically that petite : it
means small intestine because that's all
they serve neither can anyone else which
is why they shut it down we are not
eating at this restaurant
we are demolishing it ma'am may I offer
you the first whack been dreaming about
this since I was a little girl
[Music]
[Music]
guys love is beautiful come on man
here's your muscles use my muscles oh
great why didn't I think of that great
advice
Terry you know what it's a pull-up has
that much to coach here so there's
Carrie Miranda Charlotte and Samantha
but New York City is really the fifth
character hmm what about Steve you seen
guys Oh Steve is nothing no one likes
Steve Steve it nothing I don't get it
Miranda could have had blair Underwood
but she settles was Dean oh but you do
get it sir see now you do Scully
thumbs up
[Music]
job can you do it without screaming fry
Bob Lee that we're ready another sex in
the city it guilty as charged
my favorite season has to be the third
one everything was going right for
Carrie her face was on every bus her
column with the talk of the town and she
met everyone's favorite furniture maker
Aidan Shaw sure she melted down when he
tried to introduce her to experience and
she flipped out when she bumped in a big
getting out of that cab with Natasha
whom he had married who can blame her
they barely knew each other the best
episode that year was episode six
entitled are we [ __ ] you know Carrie
was all in her hand because she had Aden
weren't having sex meanwhile across town
Charlie couldn't stop having sex and
some men that Samantha was just being
Samantha the season finale that year was
entitled cockadoodledoo cockadoodledoo
Roger that
whoops I hate big Carrie should have
ended up with Mikhail Baryshnikov what
he slapped her you insane
I left my phone in the briefing room
it's been 20 minutes do you think
they're still they're not doing anything
kissing just turned to talk it's like
why even work here listen up we have an
announcement to make
when I was in that news Beck prison
choking on my own blood because my face
was being beaten in I realized life is
funny that's what you realized and it's
short we're picking up where we left off
when Adrian went into hiding we'll get
married tomorrow
Oh tomorrow that's real quick Thank You
sergeant and we wanted to be beautiful
and lush and romantic just like a Nancy
Meyers movie she's our favorite director
Wow I love you've got mail that's Nora
Ephron you idiot I know this is just 18
shots of espresso
they got me through the first three
months of having twins but I imagine
it'll sober you up too ah didn't carry
you such a good father no miss my father
used to be daddy's little girl but we
never talk anymore you don't that's what
happens you grow up your bombs your dad
goes no it doesn't always happen all
right
two special daddies who put the time in
read them stories do little pigtails
really Sarge
do you think you should do my pigtails
why can't they stay babies forever
Merlini maybe you went up the wall like
this oh never mind it's not possible
sure I'm a dark past now you know my
deepest shame go well not us on you do
it I get how to do it - oh damn Terry
yes Eunice we know who you are that
matters in the hole right now
[Music]
she's getting away again
not this time partner I see on the
ground what you're mine yes
very easily what the hell were you
thinking you're lucky you just
dislocated your knee how do you know so
hated I went to med school for three
years you did when that's not the point
why did you jump off the building I was
trying to make up for letting him get
away seven years ago I don't care about
that you had an instinct you followed
him you were wrong that happens to
everybody goodbye you good go on and
then it got more and more awkward to
bring up so I never did I just hoped
that we catch him eventually and you'd
never be tipped off to the fact that I
let him go Oh what are you doing with
your face in your voice I had an
epiphany I got really excited i moved my
knee and now i hurt a real bad okay
read through the pain until me what you
figured out someone tipped off Sergio
the cops were visiting his grandmother
and there was only one person that knew
we were cops and nurse who hates old
people Ezra course never leave your
money unprotected that's the first thing
I learned in business school also went
to business school yeah and I also have
a pilot's license whatever point is now
we have a link to Sergio so let's we'll
get him so we're good
you're not mad at me anymore no you're
about to be room out of me what I'm
gonna reset your knee look at the buddy
you